>> Laura: PROSECUTORS,
POLITICS, AND PERSONAL AMBITION.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
AS A FORMER CRIMINAL DEFENSE
ATTORNEY, I SAW MY SHARE OF
INDIVIDUALS AND COMPANIES CAUGHT
IN THE CROSS HAIRS OF GOVERNMENT
INVESTIGATORS WHO DESPERATELY
WANTED A TROPHY ON THE WALL.
WE KNOW THE SCENES.
A CEO ARRESTED AND CUFFED AT HIS
OR HER OFFICE FOR ALL THE
EMPLOYEES TO SEE FOR MAXIMUM
HUMILIATION.
A PROSECUTOR HOLDING A PRESS
CONFERENCE CLAIMING THE EVIDENCE
WILL SHOW THAT SOME HIGH PROFILE
PERSON IS GUILTY OF MYRIAD
CRIMES.
MEANING JAIL FOR THE REST OF HIS
ADULT LIFE.
TALL HIGH DRAMA.
IT'S ALL LIKE AN EPISODE OF LAW
& ORDER.
NOW OF COURSE WE NEED
PROSECUTORS TO HELP LOCK UP THE
BAD GUYS, WHETHER THEY ARE
WHITE-COLLAR CRIMINALS OR
VIOLENT OFFENDERS.
WHEN THEY ARE OPERATING
PROFESSIONALLY, TALKING ABOUT
PROSECUTORS, AND IN GOOD FAITH,
THEY SHOULD BE RECOGNIZED FOR
THE PUBLIC SERVICE THEY PROVIDE.
BUT LONG BEFORE TODAY'S IG
REPORT WAS RELEASED, COME ON,
MOST OF US KNEW THE FBI'S
HANDLING OF THE CLINTON EMAIL
EXAMPLES OF HOW CASES SHOULD NOT
BE HANDLED.
OF COURSE, THE USUAL SUSPECTS
SPENT MOST OF THE DAY
DOWNPLAYING THE FINDINGS OF THE
IG.
THE IG FOUND NO POLITICAL BIAS.
NO, IT IS JUST RUN-OF-THE-MILL
INSUBORDINATION HERE.
>> WE JUST GOT THE SAME KIND OF
HAMMER YOU USED TO ANNEAL IN A
PAINTING ON THE WALL.
THE HILLARY CASE WAS PROPERLY
DECIDED ON THE LAW.
THAT'S HEADLINE NUMBER ONE.
NUMBER TWO, NO INDICATION OR
EVIDENCE THAT POLITICAL BIASES.
>> DEEPLY DISTURBING THE
REPUBLICANS REMAIN OBSESSED WITH
UNDERMINING OUR INTELLIGENCE AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES.
>> Laura: OKAY, NICE TRY,
NANCY.
THE IG'S FINDINGS SHOW THE
OPPOSITE.
AS WE DISCUSSED EARLIER, THE
EVIDENCE SHOWS THAT FBI DIRECTOR
JIM COMEY OPERATED ACCORDING TO
HIS OWN SET OF RULES IN THE
CLINTON EMAIL INVESTIGATION.
"COMEY ADMITTED HE CONCEALED HIS
INTENTIONS FROM THE DOJ UNTIL
THE MORNING OF HIS PRESS
CONFERENCE ON JULY 5, AND
INSTRUCTED HIS STAFF TO DO THE
SAME.
WE FOUND IT WAS EXTRAORDINARY
AND INSUBORDINATE FOR COMEY TO
DO SO.
WE ACKNOWLEDGE THAT COMEY FACED
DIFFICULT CHOICES IN LATE
OCTOBER 2016.
HOWEVER, WE FOUND IT
EXTRAORDINARY THAT COMEY
ASSESSED THAT IT WAS VESTED THAT
THE FBI DIRECTOR NOT SPEAK
DIRECTLY WITH THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND THE DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL."
LIKE SO MANY PEOPLE IN THIS
TOWN, HE THOUGHT, JIM COMEY,
THAT HIS TITLE GAVE HIM A
LICENSE TO IGNORE BASIC
PROSECUTORIAL PROTOCOL.
NO WONDER HE WASN'T ALL THAT
KEEN ON PURSUING HILLARY'S USE
OF AN UNSECURED SERVER GIVEN THE
FACT THAT WE FOUND OUT TODAY
THAT HE HIMSELF WAS USING A
PERSONAL GMAIL ACCOUNT TO
CONDUCT GOVERNMENT BUSINESS.
EVEN HILLARY REFERENCED VAT IN A
TWEET TODAY.
AND IF YOU, LIKE I, THOUGHT
COMEY CAME OFF AS INCURIOUS IN
TELEVISION INTERVIEWS FOR THAT
STUPID BOOK OF HIS, CHECK OUT
THIS TWEET.
HE SAID TODAY IN A TWEET "I
RESPECT THE DOJ.
IG OFFICE WHICH IS WHY I URGE
THEM TO DO THIS REVIEW.
THE CONCLUSIONS ARE REASONABLE
EVEN THOUGH I DISAGREE WITH THEM
EVEN THOUGH I DISAGREE WITH THE
THEM.
PEOPLE OF GOOD FAITH CAN SEE AN
UNPRECEDENTED SITUATION
DIFFERENTLY.
I PRAY NO DIRECTOR FACES IT
AGAIN.
THANKS TO IG'S PEOPLE FOR HARD
WORK."
HE LOST ME AT "PEOPLE OF GOOD
FAITH."
NOTICE BY THE WAY HOW HE MAKES
HIMSELF OUT TO BE THE VICTIM
HERE.
IT'S UNBELIEVABLE.
COMEY SHOULD CHANGE HIS MIDDLE
NAME TO HUBRIS.
THE MAN HAS LEARNED ABSOLUTELY
NOTHING FROM THIS EXPERIENCE.
AND REMEMBER, BY THE WAY, THIS
IS THE GUY WHO SIGNED OFF ON
THREE FISA APPLICATIONS AND
DIDN'T THINK IT WAS NECESSARY TO
TELL THE FISA COURT THAT HILLARY
PAID FOR THE STEELE DOSSIER.
THIS IS THE SAME MAN WHO ALLOWED
PETER STRZOK, THE FBI AGENT, TO
CHANGE THE DESCRIPTION OF
MRS. CLINTON'S USE OF THE
PRIVATE SERVER FROM GROSSLY
NEGLIGENT TO MERELY EXTREMELY
CARELESS.
SO AS NOT TO TRIGGER THE
UNDERLYING CRIMINAL STATUTE.
BUT OF COURSE THERE WAS THIS
BREAKING NEWS TO COMPETE WITH
THE IG RELEASE TODAY.
>> THE NEW YORK ATTORNEY GENERAL
HAD JUST ANNOUNCED A LAWSUIT
AGAINST THE DONALD J. TRUMP
FOUNDATION.
>> FILED LESS THAN AN HOUR AGO,
A 41 PAGE CIVIL COMPLAINT
ALLEGING THAT THE DONALD J.
TRUMP FOUNDATION WAS ACTUALLY AN
EMPTY SHELL.
>> NEW YORK'S ATTORNEY GENERAL
IS SUING PRESIDENT TRUMP AND HIS
THREE OLDEST CHILDREN ALLEGING
"SELF-DEALING ANOTHER PERSISTENT
ILLEGAL CONDUCT."
>> Laura: I'M SURE THIS IS ALL
JUST COINCIDENCE, THE TIMING OF
THE LAWSUIT.
COME ON.
AGAINST THE TRUMP FOUNDATION.
IT'S BEYOND SUSPICIOUS.
REMEMBER, IT COMES FROM THE
NEW YORK ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
OFFICE.
CONSIDER THE SOURCE.
DISGRACED FORMER
ATTORNEY GENERAL OF NEW YORK
ERIC SCHNEIDERMAN WHO YOU MIGHT
REMEMBER SENT OUT A FUND-RAISING
EMAIL RIGHT AFTER THE
INVESTIGATION INTO THE
FOUNDATION WAS OPENED.
HE IS A TRULY ODIOUS FIGURE WHO
ABUSED AND HUMILIATED HIS FEMALE
VICTIMS AND THEN USED HIS OFFICE
AND HIS POSITION TO THREATEN
THEM INTO SILENCE.
MARK MY WORDS.
WE HAVEN'T HEARD THE LAST OF
WHAT HE DID TO HIS VICTIMS.
AND THE PERSON WHO CONTINUES HIS
CRUSADE, BARBARA UNDERWOOD, WHO
SET UP ON TAKING OVER FOR
SCHNEIDERMAN, "I BELIEVE THIS
JOB AT THIS MOMENT IN HISTORY IS
THE MOST IMPORTANT JOB I HAVE
EVER HAD."
YEAH, LITTLE SUBTLETY THERE.
THINK ABOUT IT.
DONALD TRUMP OPERATED A
FOUNDATION THAT HAD ZERO
OVERHEAD, NO ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS, AND GAVE AWAY MORE THAN
$19 MILLION TO A VARIETY OF
CHARITABLE CAUSES.
TRUMP AND HIS COMPANIES
PERSONALLY PORT $8 MILLION INTO
THE FOUNDATION.
NOW THERE WAS A MISTAKE AND
CONTRIBUTION MADE TO PAT BONDI'S
CAMPAIGN BUT IT WAS RECTIFIED
ONCE IT WAS DISCOVERED.
IN OTHER WORDS, THIS IS A
PENNY-ANTE STUFF THAT WOULD
NEVER BE PURSUED BY THE
NEW YORK STATE OF
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE IF
DONALD TRUMP HADN'T GOTTEN INTO
POLITICS.
IT'S ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF
POLITICIZED LAW ENFORCEMENT, AND
ABUSE OF PROCESS.
THIS TIME IT WAS THROUGH A CIVIL
ACTION ON THE STATE LEVEL.
WHERE WERE THEY, BY THE WAY COME
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL WHEN THE
CLINTON FOUNDATION WAS ACCEPTING
FUNDS FROM FOREIGN GOVERNMENTS
WHILE HILLARY WAS SECRETARY OF
STATE?
SOME OF THEM WANTS TO GET
MEETINGS WITH HILLARY.
MEANWHILE, COMEY AND HIS
POLITICAL ACTIVISTS POSING AS
AGENTS VENT THE LEGAL STANDARDS
FOR HILLARY CLINTON, ALLOWING
HER TO WALK FREE.
AND THEY ASSUMED THAT SHE WAS
GOING TO BE GOING INTO THE
WHITE HOUSE.
LET'S NOT FORGET.
CLINTON IS SETTING UP THAT
PRIVATE SERVER, MADE UP HER OWN
RULES, JUSTICE COMEY DID IN
CLEARING HER OF ANY CRIMINAL
WRONGDOING.
MY FRIENDS, THIS IS ALL A
HIDEOUS PERVERSION OF JUSTICE.
NOW FBI DIRECTOR CHRISTOPHER
WRAY IS INSISTING THE IG REPORT
CLEARS THE FBI, THOUGH, OF
STRUCTURAL RESPONSIBILITY.
>> NOTHING, NOTHING IN THIS
REPORT IMPUGNS THE INTEGRITY OF
OUR WORKFORCE AS A WHOLE.
>> I'M SORRY.
YOU ARE WRONG.
THERE ARE CONSEQUENCES.
THE CONSEQUENCES ARE THAT YOUR
FELLOW CITIZENS QUESTION WHETHER
OR NOT THEY CAN HAVE CONFIDENCE
IN THE WORLD'S PREMIER
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY.
>> Laura: REMEMBER WHEN JIM
COMEY SAID THIS?
>> IT MAKES ME MILDLY NAUSEOUS
TO THINK WE MIGHT HAVE HAD SOME
IMPACT ON THE ELECTION.
>> Laura: [LAUGHS]
IT MAKES ME WILDLY NAUSEOUS
READING THIS IG REPORT AND
LEARNING HOW COMEY AND HIS